ma davvero devo farci episodi gli sta
roba bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fa vj oggi siamo
tornati su troppi squestro videogames
due erano rimasti ragazzi che sembrano i
miei ex compagni di classe durante
matematica posso provare a schiacciare
sulle rane
[Musica]
chissà come mai mi aspettavo sicuramente
non devo fare niente che c'entri col
colore ellera nicolò sicuro prove
[Risate]
[Musica]
oh the sims che bello vediamo se parlano
anche quei personaggi di the sims poco
ci manca
anche facendo lo sta dice c'è un cesso
di no come non ho vinto neanche così
quindi non devo farli morire che strano
devo farli cadere qualcosa in testa ecco
non avevo dubbi
perfetto non ci avevo pensato
sinceramente cioè mi è andata abbastanza
di cui andiamo avanti o questo sono io
[Musica]
teramo donna secondo scarso ottica gli
addosso ma sono io veramente faremo nei
graber gameplay a proprio a ho messo dei
soldi dentro il treviso va bene e va
spesso invaders è diventato l'ultima che
avevo
[Musica]
funziona sta cosa
un limbo ma dai è stato difficile che
sto facendo
cosa li vuoi dare astone garagna una
scarpa non credo che sia molto
interessanti ho come l'impressione che
potevi aspettarti puoi provare a dargli
dovresti da linee 8 ritrattati scarpe
una non se ne fa niente
e tra l'altro mi uccide nello stesso
sotto modo di comuni uccide in limbo
magari devi allora ha posto alla madonna
povero ragno poverino appena anche nel
gioco anche se fa abbastanza schifo
quindi deve morire però che bello anche
video ficcare dei soldi ma qua non c'è
una carta di picche adesso sui soldi
l'effetto ho perso però va bene tra
l'altro mi spieghi perché una carta con
un p che dovrebbe darti dei soldi se la
infili nel bancomat per come sa no
chiaro successo io vi giuro più vado
avanti più vorrei uccidermi non si
capisce ma cos'è devo fermarla nel punto
giusto
bravissimo faccio un po caga rossi che
però almeno ho fatto schifo
l'importante è crederci raga 1 io sapevo
che centrava la merda l'ho detto prima
andiamo avanti bioshock ma da quant'è
che non lo vedo sto gioco da secoli si è
addormentato di me li puoi fare niente
sta dormendo
ok sono andato sì sì sì
fate sì con la testa a tutti i tuoi sisi
abbiamo tutti capito perché lo sterco
c'entra in tutti i livelli perché perché
ma basta o capi questo è svenuto predica
gare ma ti rendi conto dell'intelligenza
di sti giochi cioè non so abbiamo fatto
a scaricarlo
cosa su cosa ho visto una scura talmente
potente da da lanciare via g il cesso
beh ci sta ho visto di peggio perché
dovresti cucinare un gambero a ti piace
così tanto perché fuoco e verde notifica
gare da qualche parte visto che si parla
sempre e solo di guerra mi sto gioco lo
vedo che non è convinto sembra poi mio
padre sto tizio agli stessi capelli
soprattutto lo sapevo dovevo zoomare sul
sul gambero fallito ua e allora sei
stupido
[Musica]
sai cosa mi ha fatto scattare non lo so
perché va bene così oh mio dio è devoto
lunga volevo giocarlo ma dopo questo
video probabimente non l'ho proprio
hanno tolto il fiocco a porca vacca e mi
sa che non è andata proprio benissimo 9
che un lato è brutto impegnati un po
madonna a selena gomez a me va bene
anche così c'è anche se è montata al
contrario va benissimo guardati giorno
un problema sorge un simulator il turi
non mi aspettavo niente di meglio dove
lo assicuro ragazzi pennarello senza
dubbio guarani fatto di peggio io non ho
disegnato beni devi essere contento pure
le pinze ma neanche con quel e va bene
[Musica]
va bene ma che senso aveva mai nella
vita versate le pinze
una volta giura di aver fatto la stessa
cosa e ne è uscito uno talmente grosso
che più o meno pensavo di aver partorito
il fratello giulio ok next non mio dio è
una challenge rivelarlo lo skeet poi
social face questo chiarissimo bene si è
passati dal fare le cose dal culo a dal
naso adesso comune come a livello di
prima uguale non ho dubbi
siamo tornati sulla cacca grazie a dio
ultimi tre livelli raga sono proprio
intensi saranno zoomato e ho già fatto
giusto perché zoomare difficile è the
witcher questo sì questo perché faccia
adesso puoi lavorare in pace bravo così
zio perfetto se viene pulirmi casa ti do
5 euro al minuto
ciao è infatti questo non anche
sbagliato una volta non sapevo neanche
come si sbagliava perfetto pinball un
paiato ok alla prima carica di più ha
dovuto solo a questioni di zuwarah che
ogni volta che botta va bene perfetto
raga gli ultimi due livelli incredibile
poverino che triste a devo fare qualcosa
in ogni stanza chiaro ok
ok è l'ultima stanza
[Applauso]
e quindi una volta arrivato qua che devo
fare lo tira del cesso anno debutta
ultimo livello
non oso pensare vai mario kart è
l'ultimo mario kart e l'ultimo livello
va bene fa via dari che sei capace
schifo apre 5 sapete che dovete premere
tipo nei primi due secondi tener premuto
il tasto per andare più veloce
all'inizio è uguale solo che lui non
parte proprio devo togliere lo so ok
devo togliere lo sono ancora oddio che è
presa male regala bellissimo va bene è
la finale questo ho finito tutti i
livelli
cioè io credo che l'esperienza dei
videogiocatori si vede anche in queste
cose cioè non finire i giochi importante
finire trophies qu'est ce l'ha ma che
roba va ma è stato orribile arrivo
voglio mai più vedere una roba del
genere corribile per ora gazzoli bellis
spero che il video vi sia piaciuto come
se mi piace commenta mi piace anche
questo segmento da iniziare cesare si
stia dei e non ci vediamo
[Musica]